stop the show Gang get an important
announcement the boys are doing a live
stream New Year's Day come hang out with
the squad down here with Toadies we're
gonna have some special guests might be
an appearance from Patty and Denise you
don't know what's gonna happen it's
gonna be a good time get a hair and a
dog in you kick off 2023 right and that
ain't it you bozos we got a third show
at the Gramercy theater shout out to the
army of garbage baby we're on sale now
our third show it's going to be February
3rd that's a Friday night get your
tickies now New York City Army of
garbage let's go welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
favorite new podcast this is are you
garbage well shall we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find it at the
group to be classy yeah or if they're
just a big old piece of trash I'm your
host Dave truly coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antuti's basement she's upstairs has her
eye on that new divorcee that moved in
across the street okay says he's Easy
Pickins my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he is the CEO of are
you garbage he's an international
businessman but he always gives back to
the community give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan hey what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate you subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are over a
hundred thousand baby then obviously the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage love
that money baby and then we just
announced our third date at The Gramercy
theater it's on sale we sold out the
first two in like two days get those
tickets to the third one before they
sell out do it do it gang and grab
tickets a live stream and the live
stream on January 1st oh New Year's Day
come see us gang it's going to be fun
and how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer X Jordan Air the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
and twos crosses the t's dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone McMuffin Toby
McMullen everybody hey what's up dudes
what's up I'm excited nope this guy
didn't bring us bread but he did bring
us Al Capone's hat
I see gentlemen in here gang a long hair
ain't lying because we couldn't be more
excited to have our incredibly and I
mean incredibly special guest here with
us today for the first time he is a
legendary stand-up comedian actor writer
podcaster and producer and you may have
seen him in but not limited to here we
go we got B movie Analyze That New
Adventures of Old Christine the
informant Behind the Candelabra Inside
Amy Schumer top five the Nick the Jim
Gaffigan show Red Oaks paper spiders
North Hollywood he has two Comedy
Central presents he wrote 22 Episodes of
the marriage ref you've also seen him in
the comedian Carson Daly Conan O'Brien
The Late Show Oprah ever heard of her
Jimmy Kimmel Live a worker Last Comic
Standing your mom's house The Tonight
Show this is not happening cop show
Larry Wilmore Craig Ferguson something's
burning WTF Colbert lights out with
David Spade Joe Rogan Seth Meyers and
he's going to be in the brand new Ben
Affleck Matt Damon movie entitled Air
Jordan you can hear him every week on
his amazing podcast breaking bread with
Tom Papa and A Serious XM show with
Fortune feemster what a joke specials
include geez calm cool and collected Tom
Papa live in New York City freaked out
human wool human mule you're doing great
and he has a brand new Netflix special
out right now called what a day but the
big question everybody's mind is he
garbage like the boy said first gotta
walk in here with a fedora and pull it
off
ladies and gentlemen give it up for Mr
Tom Papa
congratulations thank you very much why
live stream on New Year's Day uh it's
like a hangover show we're gonna live
stream for a minute and you know
hangover get a little bit of hair of the
dog you know so how do you play will you
just go rip it up on New Year's and kind
of come in a mess or do you that's
that's style it back that's the plan no
we're going heavy yes you know come
correct or don't come at all I like it I
like to come in hammered I'm gonna be
drinking alka-seltzers and vodka I gotta
be honest I opened the door to let Tom I
thought it was a hitman
I was like I thought he was the landlord
about to evict us I didn't know what was
going on this is the classiest dress guy
we've had in Jimmy scagnetti says hello
Jesus that's a sharp hat man yeah you
could get the cannoli
I'm imagining that you're going to be
all class you're a sharp guy you carry
yourself very sharp I'm very interested
but he is from Jersey I believe Jersey
that's a little dirt under the finger
now yeah good point good point give us
the origin story of Tom Papa give us to
give us the whole scoop born in uh
Passaic New Jersey okay
uh grew up as a jersey kid
uh my parents met in high school they're
still together now nice
um I'm the oldest of three okay younger
sisters grew up mostly in uh Park Ridge
and Woodcliff Lake New Jersey okay up
north
went to high school there uh I was class
clown and captain of the football team
hey this guy does it all I had the combo
uh and then I uh from King and prom
queen he wanted to be wanted to be a
comedian since I was seventh grade okay
and but my parents wanted me to go to
college so I went to Rider College yeah
my brother went there yeah last semester
yeah there's a lot of that I described
it down the street from Princeton
uh you go to Princeton yeah right down
95. yeah right here you play ball there
you play football there no that's why I
went there was they had gotten in
trouble and they their football program
was disbanded they had no football and I
was done with football I went from
kindergarten to 12th grade
I was uh my high school career I was uh
full back in defensive end
and I was uh but I was done I knew I
wasn't going to keep it is this North
Jersey you're playing this is North
Jersey what high school Hills that's
pretty good squad it was a good squad
yeah it was a good squad a lot of
talented kids we were like a little over
we were probably we we missed like we
had a coach Fallout our senior year they
fired our coach and brought a new guy in
kind of messed everything up but uh we
were we were winning like all the way
through and then that year was just kind
of done and I was done just yeah yeah
I'm not gonna my father was like maybe
play division three and I was like maybe
not maybe maybe it's time to go be a
comedian you're like Mean Joe Green ice
in your knees
yeah you're 18. it's in the best shape
of your life I want to spend more time
with my family
so I went there because they they had
theater department but they didn't have
football okay smart and so kind of took
it out of uh that debate out of uh out
of the house so then I went there I
started acting and stuff got through
four years got out graduated graduated
yeah did ba in acting uh in
Communications okay and but spend all my
time in the theater the whole time was
just in the theater doing the plays that
was it I just did that non-stop got uh
out of school moved up to Paramus uh
lived in Paramus and saw in the Village
Voice that uh I started I took some
acting classes and I was like how do I
audition for stuff what are you doing in
Paramus uh it was close to the city oh
okay and I couldn't afford the city yet
and I was but I wanted to be a comedian
and I realized I opened the Village
Voice and so I can do an open mic at New
York comedy club or I could try and get
parts like through I was like well this
thing sounds better yeah
do the thing five of my friends sit in
the audience I'm gonna be on stage on
June 12 1993. there you go and uh I went
and I did it and I was hooked the only
other comedian in the place was Greg
Giraldo who was a young girl shout out
to the greatest the greatest you're
waiting to go on all nervous and we
became Pals and uh then I just started I
was like I was hooked and you know the
first couple first three years you do
like one set every two months or so sure
but you're a comedian I felt like I was
a comedian I stayed in New York became a
comic
uh eventually met my wife who was a
comedian at the comic strip when I was
passing the concert okay she grew up in
the same Hometown that I grew up in did
you know her there the same kindergarten
teacher we were a year apart never met
really yeah that was my opening line did
you have Miss Conway for kindergarten
yeah
and I was like uh so then we we had all
the shared history and stuff sure like
oh we're gonna we're gonna get married
right and I said to her like immediately
you're gonna have my babies and she
that's not off-putting up front she got
she did shots the rest of the night and
threw up in my bathtub
no lie she was like what is your plan
and uh
so uh became a comic met her in 93
became a comic uh in 93 we started
living with her around 98. okay uh had
our first baby and got married had her
in 2000 had her first baby like 2002 had
uh two kids uh just went through the
ranks and did all the stuff that you
were mentioning in that great intro and
um and now my kids are 17 and 20. and
I'm here with you guys yeah that was
that was absolutely crazy talk about an
elevator
this guy's gone who's gonna play you
I see a young Joe Namath playing here
um take me back to uh take you back to
Jersey what'd your mom and dad do what'd
your dad do for a living my father was
in sales okay he was uh in early
Communications company so like uh GTE
and those kind of come they were like it
was the beginning of uh what is now like
you know the big Communication Company
sure it was the beginning of that and he
was a cte's old school old school yeah
yeah and uh he was very successful he
became like the national guy he was he
was
into sales but he was also uh he also
rode motorcycles was not into like
corporate culture but he was in there
that's what his career was Renegade but
he was a renegade okay he would come to
my games when I was a kid and like on
his motorcycle what are we talking about
Choppers no like uh like Harley's
eventually was all Harleys okay that it
was like big Honda Gold Wings and stuff
like that but then it was electroglides
and and all that stuff it's pretty sweet
yeah what about your mom my mom was a
mom for the beginning and then when I
was around uh maybe like Junior High she
went back to school to get her degree
okay got her degree started a small
advertising agency on her own uh in
northern New Jersey
a whole lot of them
and she also drove race cars
parking my games in a race car
and she started a small advertising
agency and did that for like I don't
know 15 years or so damn where'd she go
back to school where'd she get her to
Grandma po okay and where'd your dad go
to school my father went to uppsala okay
which if you're going down the Garden
State Parkway I don't know like when you
get into the it's gone now okay but if
you go down the Garden State Parkway
there's like a field when you get in the
oranges there's like this old field over
there that's where he played football
okay so he was division three like he
was really good like he went to Clifton
High School is where they met and he was
the captain of that team and that was
back like when you see pictures like now
it's unusual to see a guy in a hat the
the pictures of him playing in high
school it'd be 3 000 people in hash sure
like hash jackets High School football
like it was the thing yeah and uh and
they was the state champion and all that
stuff so he went to division three and
kept playing damn but uh I was not
interested at that point it's a solid
American family right you said you're
the old you're the oldest of your
siblings how many what do you have two
sisters two sisters one of these sisters
uh one uh you're gonna hate this she
runs a non-profit uh Farm in uh New
Jersey that's great in northern New
Jersey she CR she's got these there's
all these farmlands and this guy's
[ __ ] born
she got all these Farmland you're gonna
hate this yeah exactly Mother Teresa you
haven't heard of her you're gonna hate
this she she helps people and makes no
money Jesus Christ
I told you you weren't gonna like it
she's giving Jersey he just gave me like
John Q America's whole family I know
she's giving [ __ ] she's giving out free
carrots to Patterson
it's her whole gig it's called City
green
and uh she's built it up over like 10 15
years amazing it's a huge thing yeah
it's she's really and your other sister
my other please tell me she's in a band
or something
you're not gonna like this
he makes she makes a little money but
very little money I only want to say it
working with autistic children
I mean they're these poppers I tell you
yes [ __ ] they're kind of they're kind of
Saint like both of them so your dad did
well growing up you guys you guys were
doing okay my father was came from a
family of uh of seven seven
they had no money okay at all they grew
up in Clifton they had zero money and uh
they had to like scrape and but a lot of
love a big Italian family sure and uh
I'm one of 21
grandchildren they were all around you
too when you grew up although yeah
family we would meet at my grandmother's
house in Clifton where they grew up
which was like a two-bedroom apartment
really right and all these people would
just stuff in and we just had uh we just
had our fail it's my responsibility now
to keep the Christmas
get together you're going and now it's
like you know if all in it's probably 75
people so where do you do it at like
where were you where are you going this
year with this we we've been doing it
traditionally at Mario's Pizza in on Van
Houten Avenue this guy's trying to live
here you go two slices for Christmas
and uh it's like a pizza joint like a
red sauce kind of place and it's you
know the food's okay
I've been there since seventh yeah but
it's you know they got a big room in the
shop and one of those kind of things and
uh this year I was flat I organized it
all and I was flying in on Sunday and
when I landed the first text I saw was
Mario's is on fire question mark
yeah you deposit back Tommy
surprise your family that the Volunteer
Fire Company
don't worry we're on our way we're gonna
save Christmas
just throw some carrot sticks on it
so we got so we had to call an audible
and go to my uh sister's house she ended
up hosting it 75 people are they mostly
local it was uh it was probably about 50
people okay for this one well you guys
already did this this was Sunday you did
it on Sunday okay yeah all right cool so
you'll do the holidays the actual
holidays back with your family yeah well
I'm running around doing stuff my family
my wife and kids are going to be here in
New York okay like we'll we'll hit all
the East Coast people and your parents
and all that stuff up till like the 20th
or so and then go back to uh La man
papas are all right yeah we're moving
around
um your parents don't still live in the
same house you grew up in do they
no and it's a it's a kind of a horse or
sore spot okay really yeah they sold it
out right out from under me I was in my
mind so that's where I grew up how dare
you they want to live in a town is that
you don't want to shovel anymore
I dare you no that's gonna be worth it
if you
School District
it wasn't it wasn't a big money spot but
it was our spot and of course sure but
thankfully because my wife grew up so
when I moved I moved and didn't meet my
wife until the comic strip uh I moved
one town over so she kept going in Park
Ridge I went to Cliff Lake in one town
over gotcha and lived in that in that
house uh for our whole life so now it's
gone
uh but her brother
still lives in Park Ridge so so you get
the vibe you can still go like when my
kids and it was it was great like
because we could go back to like you
know on Christmas Eve when Santa comes
on the truck down truck yeah and you put
the kids on your shoulder it was like
clean Living Clean living and then my
parents sold it and moved ruined
everything ruined everything what was
the name of that street that you grew up
on Lori Court Laurie
I was doing a show in Florida I was
doing a show in Florida
uh in Orlando like a month ago and I
signed books at the end of the show you
know right so I signed do a book signing
at the end and uh there were these three
women with these matching t-shirts with
fluorescent something written on them I
couldn't tell what it was you know and
eventually they come up in the line and
it says they all three had I grew up on
nine Lori Court no way it was the girls
who lived in the house before we bought
it holy [ __ ] yeah back in uh like in I
don't know 76 or 78 something like that
they had grew up grown up it was the
yeah the Ricardo kids
we're grown women making wacky t-shirts
at my at my show uh I feel like every
windowsill in the story has an apple pie
cool yeah
a candle in it
definitely some toboggans leaning up
against the door
we did have a little Hill in the back
that we would slay right down of course
the Ricardos were remembering it finally
until the Weinstein's put up pine trees
and blocked us from going down the hill
yeah old man Weinstein he's still at it
I tell you old cold-hearted bastard a
lot of baseballs in his yard yeah yeah
you papa kids get out of here uh what's
the grocery store that your mom went to
Growing Up the grocery store my mom went
to when I was growing up uh that would
be ShopRite
shoprite's a fine establishment street
name the grocery store they they they
tell us a little bit okay where do you
go now uh I go to Gelson's okay in uh in
uh Los Angeles okay you don't do that
air one I don't do the air one Gelson's
is between the Ralphs and the air okay
right it's a like the Ralph's people
think it's too expensive the air one I
think people think it's garbage yeah
yeah yeah okay not bad how about the
mall growing up what's the name of that
the Paramus Park Mall not bad the
Paramus Park Mall Mario's would be the
local pizza joint Mario's was that was
for my parents okay
um we had Phils Phil's Phils in Montvale
not bad yeah Phil's how about the
Chinese spot what was the name of the
Chinese place you guys would go to I
don't remember the name of it would you
do Chinese food as a kid we would do
Chinese food once in a while okay we
were more pizza and then Chicken Delight
but chicken the light sounds all right
I'm not gonna lie it's still there yeah
really still there making good on out
buckets of Chicken Fried Chicken Fried
Chicken local Fried Chicken local Fried
Chicken that ain't bad yeah really good
yeah really good uh drink milk with
dinner growing up uh yes really the time
I saw my father laugh the hardest in his
life I was always funny and I was always
trying to make people laugh and he was
tough to crack but one day after
practice of some sort I came poured
myself a glass of milk and sat down at
the table and took a swig and had chunks
in it and I spit it up and my father
left
for a week straight I respect that I
respect that I knew it was bad let you
drink it anyway
Kevin's talking about that rocket money
love that rock of money yeah a lot of
you bozos out there think you spend
about 80 on subscriptions when you
actually got about 200 some of you don't
even know about you guys are getting
fleece you got your eye the wool pull
over your eyes bombs are ripping you off
and sometimes they double charge you you
don't even know yeah that's why Rock and
money can help you out yeah formerly
known as true bill baby the app shows
you all of your subscriptions in one
place and cancels whatever ones you
don't want rocket money can even find
subscription you didn't even know you
were paying for which happened to me I
didn't know I got money out on the
streets all over the place everybody's
got their hands in my pocket damn Planet
Fitness uh to cancel any subscription uh
just press cancel and Rocket money takes
care of the rest easy peasy lemon
squeezy get rid of useless subscriptions
with rocket money now go to
rocketmoney.com garbage seriously can
save you hundreds of dollars a year and
all who don't need a couple Hyundai
every year that's rocketmoney.com
garbage cancel your unnecessary
subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com garbage one more time
get a pen get a pencil rocketmoney.com
garbage today do it Kevin's talking
about Adam and Eve oh yeah let's talk
about stuffing those stocks stuffing a
little more than stocking bring your
turkey over here I'll stop that too
dang Adam and Eve is the best man yeah
what a good time to explore the holiday
season you started sticking your finger
up your butt go to Adam and Eve you can
get 50 off almost any items shove right
up your ass it ain't no candy cane I'll
tell you that great whatever they got in
there stick your pee pee in something
yeah get it going here it's a good time
man I get hit with a blowtorch just to
move this thing
guys it's great they sent it to us I
mean I'm you know I got something on me
right now I'm controlling it with my
phone
uh guys you get a flashlight for him
Benoit balls for her uh Adam and Eve has
it all all package you need is discreet
it doesn't come and say hey there's a
there's a creep in 4B and don't do that
your mailman don't know what's happening
and he's probably on adamandeve.com so
go to adamandeers.com
those postal workers are freaking
naughty uh select any one item and use
code garbage this is an exclusive offer
so
be sure to support the show and use code
garbage to get 50 off and free shipping
go to adamandeve.com right now do it now
my father and I bonded over food I'll
give you a little white trash in okay A
little uh we he loved White Castle all
right loved White Castle and it was our
father bonding moment to uh sit in the
winter in his car with like 50 50 all on
the dashboard
come on Tom you can do it eat another
one yeah all right that's pretty good uh
What was your first job
my first job I used to cut lawns okay
and uh I used to cut lawns and uh on
your own or force them on my own really
yeah whose mower would you use uh my our
Lawn Boy our green one there you go
handle pull start you'd have to do your
yard I assume I had to do my yard too
okay for that at all did you get like
five bucks or whatever to do it I don't
think from my father I didn't I think he
he got to do that one on a cuff yeah he
was like you know you're you're yeah I
was so young like we had a hill in the
back and you had to mow it I was so
young that I had the top handle and my
friend Keith had the middle
employees
to get it up the hill yeah and I used to
have a joke in my ACT early on I don't
know what the joke was but it was about
a real situation where my father like if
something got stuck my father would be
like you with a small hand put it in
there and get the piece of wood out of
there and I'm like I would never took my
child reaching a dark hole to get
something sharp out right exactly out of
a spinning lawn mower there's different
rules back then baby well that was the
first that was the first one the first
job the first like and then I worked the
landscaping for a friend who had like a
landscaping company gotcha and then uh
and then I worked at uh you go cars
remember you go yeah you go they had a
uh a plant or a warehouse in uh like
Mawa and uh which is the classic joke
here today gone to Mawa yeah
and uh I used to work in there that was
kind of silly and I worked for UPS a
little bit in high school no uh loading
in the big tractor trailers so you
worked all through high school you're
playing football yeah the graves were
good I assume grades were like uh C plus
B minus whatever wouldn't whatever
degree maybe whatever would make uh
whatever would keep me out of trouble
did you take the SATs I took the SATs
you remember what you got 1100 really
yeah pretty good
man yeah it got me into Rider yeah you
said you played defensive end and
fullback yeah were you playing both ways
in every game yeah both sides of the
ball Tom yeah well we were small school
yeah we're not that big he's playing
everything
throwing it to himself Papa drops back
throws the papa papa with a great catch
oh tackled by Papa
let's get over to head coach
folks this is Tom Papa signing off I
would be surprised it's a goddamn this
guy's doing it all cheerleader give me a
tea give me it up oh check out the games
really you got the squad going this year
Papa throws a flag
we got it
I think Papa's smoking a doobie
underneath the bleachers there ah that
Papa kid all right here comes officer
you're having a nice big round of
applause for me and Papa everybody
we'll be right back with more news from
Papa Bear
on your local Papa State man
who would babysit you as a kid
um uh we had uh Susan famulari oh that's
such a that's such a North Jersey
babysitter talk about a bullseye we got
to watch uh her boyfriend get to second
Pace with her
so that's what I'm doing you'll never
forget that through the basement window
oh yeah they thought they were being
Slappy you guys went outside and we went
outside and around those little that
little window yeah that goes into the
basement yeah we all loaded up in there
and uh we saw some boobies yeah
for everybody involved in this everybody
wins everybody wanted that story that's
awesome
shout out to her how about the papa
family vacations where would you guys go
uh mostly the Jersey Shore nice Long
Beach Island oh yeah I know it very well
LBI love it still go still go all the
time we're outside of Philly so we did
South Jersey further south right
jersey outside of Philly or no
Pennsylvania yeah outside of Philly yeah
we'd go down to like uh Wildwood
Ocean City right right yeah all right
any uh trips to Disney World or
Disneyland yeah we had a trip to Disney
uh I guess the when I was like in I
don't know maybe like sixth grade you
fly or drive flew okay probably People's
Express something like Eastern Airlines
I know Eastern Airlines yeah and not for
good reasons
I don't know them because they're not
Hospitality
what was the family car growing up uh
the family car my mother drove a she
drove a Ford Pinto okay until those were
deemed unsafe yeah they weren't they
exploding or something they were
exploding if someone if someone would
rear end you the whole thing with the
whole neighborhood yeah uh so she got a
great area to a Chevy Chevette nice okay
which was pretty good until the cat peed
in the front in the front carpet and and
that'll ruin it it really it was so we
had to cut the carpet out we just kept
driving it for another couple of years
with a metal at the bottom sure and then
my father had a bunch of different cars
you know he had his motorcycle but he
also had like uh like Buicks okay you
know like big sedans just eight track
big sedan bench seat in the front bench
seat in the front uh in the early Parts
but then then it's like a classy where
was the motorcycle parked motorcycle is
usually parked in the garage in front of
whatever car was pulled in he would get
it up against the wall or sometimes in
between where the two cars go and it was
the cars that were parked on the grass
or anything like that of the motorcycle
or no okay yeah kept it kept it tight he
did he kept the appearance of the house
he walked by the Papa's Place uh it's
pretty tight he definitely had a I don't
give a [ __ ] about the yard kind of vibe
he wasn't into he lived in Suburbia and
worked corporate but he wasn't like he
was wasn't his thing he took real Pride
that our mailbox was just a
Rusty stick with a rusty thing with
broken like everyone had these real
ornate in the neighborhood you know like
the wood and the keep the tax man on
your name on it and all of that my
father had he just really took pride in
never upgrading his mailbox it was kind
of that sounds all right his Fu to the
neighborhood and uh the Landscaping you
know was left to me yeah with my lawn
boy and everybody had like professional
landscape and beautiful Lawns ours was a
disaster okay pool in the backyard or no
no pool no pool community pool where
would you guys go swimming community
pool nice The Old Mill yeah that's the
most American name ever yeah it is was
there a high dive no no high dive it was
a uh a uh what's like a raft kind of
situation you just have to swim out to
the diving boards off of a uh not a raft
a uh
what's a floaty in the middle of the
dock is that a pool it was a pool it's
called The Old Mill pool but it was like
part sand and then part concrete I'm so
confused but that sounds all right and
the diving board was in the middle of
the pool and yeah like out in the deep
end that's where the the dock was with
the diving board that sounds awesome
yeah it was pretty cool that's [ __ ]
sweet yeah with your dad's motorcycle
did you ever take it out joyriding no no
could can you ride one yeah I started
riding and uh
yeah yeah and that's old school that's
sweet yeah it was pretty cool okay that
is that is like probably very cool yeah
hell of a snack bar at that place I
would imagine uh not a great snack bar
but uh fusco's which was like a little
general store was like right up the
street so you could walk you could uh
squeeze yourself through the fence yep I
did the same right yeah and walked
Barefoot up to fusco's get your Funyuns
and your Fritos yeah and uh and then
come back ooh yeah a slice of Americana
right there shout out to the Funyuns
yeah uh what did you just ask before
they went back to the Old Mill
motorcycle ride oh motorcycle yeah no I
uh I started riding when I was in
graduated college my father because this
was really just to keep my mother off of
his back she didn't really like that he
rode her motorcycle all that much sure
and he would go on a trip every June him
and his friends would go somewhere for
like two weeks right out and ride out
and go yeah like down to uh damn like
anywhere in the country and uh my mother
did not like these trips sure and his if
I had in her head he's out right what
the Hell's Angels yeah right exactly and
if I had started riding then it would
have caused a big problem for him yeah
because she would have been like look
what you're doing right you're
influencing the Child leave the boy
alone who's gonna cut the grass now he
has no sleeves on your shirt smoking
hair it's all greased up my father comes
home where's my bike
and uh so I started riding in college
and then uh I've got a bike in this
apartment where I was living this guy
had a garage with this
um uh Honda Hawk in there a 550 Honda
Hawk so I bought it from him and I
started riding and then I started going
on the trips with them with my father
and all that stuff yeah and I rode until
my daughter was born and then I stopped
in yeah which makes sense man yeah he's
all right he's not a lot of dirt on him
so far his dad seems a little you know a
little wonky but he's like this way yeah
yeah in a good way I like it when was
the last time you were at an Olive
Garden
uh I uh I probably went once by mistake
by mistake I had to ask for directions
how do I get that out of this part of
town you like a little bit of the finer
thing you like to do things correct I do
I do you like to do things correct I
like to do things correctly it's been a
long journey to get to correct sure no I
understand you know I grew up in New
Jersey I didn't really know from correct
right in a lot in some ways you know
sure
um so it's kind of a I'm still learning
how to kind of figure it out what uh
what Mayo do you guys use at the house
now do you have Hellman's no Miracle
Whip no but you know Hellman's is not
that big West Coast right something else
so you end up with some Miracle Whip
sometimes really yeah if you're in a jam
I'm not happy not by choice
it's a geography problem
um what are you keep in the butter these
days keep it on the counter you keep it
in the fridge we keep it on the butter
my wife has won that War I used to on
the counter I used to keep it in the
fridge or uh she wanted it on the
counter nice and soft yep
um
and I did Martha Stewart's show
and uh I was doing like a cooking
segment with her and I asked her uh you
know solve this we might finally I mean
this is like what the show is based on
this one question and uh I said you know
my wife likes to keep do you keep the
butter in the fridge or on the on the
counter my wife uh keeps it on the
counter and Martha Stewart was chopping
something she went oh no not on the
counter really wow and wait what and
just kept going away shout out to Martha
yeah she keeps it in the fridge keeps it
in the fridge and yeah that's what she
said and then I thought well I win this
argument I got Martha Stewart on myself
yeah of course but fast forward it's
still on the counter
it's on a coffee table now just to show
you sticks everywhere
there you go
what kind of syrup are you using at the
house you have regular like uh Mrs
Butterworth or you guys use the the pure
maple syrup and it's uh it's my wife is
uh really into it I make a lot of bread
I bake sourdough I'm well aware and one
of the things you can do with sourdough
starter when you have extra is make
sourdough waffles the next day and uh so
I make that stuff but to be honest I
would probably take whatever syrup you
got but my wife is uh really hardcore
maple syrup like if we're out places
it's an uncomfortable moment in the
restaurant
she asked for Maple or if they say they
have it and they bring it and it's not
and we have no idea the kids are like
just about to pour it out no no no no no
no we will not have this I bet you
Sunday breakfast at the papa household
is probably I can feel it I can feel the
love he's got a newspaper going smell
the coffee fresh bread what kind of
Grill what kind of coffee are you doing
over there you French Press what do you
like no I'm doing uh pour over I'm
grinding beans and then doing the pour
over because I'm the only one that
drinks the coffee well actually now my
kids are drinking but they have a uh
they have these are the Nespresso
espresso and my father we had the one
with the small like espresso shots my
father who comes to visit likes more
coffee so we got the the longer bigger
ones yeah and that's what my daughter
will make iced coffee with but I like to
just grind these really good beans and
then the pour overs it's like in a cone
yeah yeah
it takes a little bit but it smells so
good I got really into that one time of
like I was figuring researching how to
chop the you chop the beans in a certain
way you poured a certain yeah stare at a
certain direction for a different time
yeah yeah my OCD really kicked in yeah
it still sucked I wasn't good at it yeah
there was a New Yorker cartoon of
somebody doing a pour over in the coffee
machine's going they'll be back it's
exactly what happened
it was worse than Dunkin Donuts
are you an espresso man after dinner if
you go out to a restaurant will you have
a nice espresso that is one of my uh
that is that is it's one of my failings
I would love an espresso every night
after dinner sure the caffeine but if I
I'll be up till two I'll lay down I'll
think I'm tired and lights yeah eyes
just pop open it sucks it's such a great
Mo there's nothing better sambuca oh
it's such a great moment Kip butcher box
holidays holiday holiday season what are
you gonna do get your meat at the
grocery store like a lady that's what
hobos do I heard yeah no kidding you
know it's a gentlemen you know where
that's coming from gang you want top
Quality Meat you want grass-fed you want
grass finish you want wild caught wow
you want free range you want delicious
meat sent right to your door you throw
it right in the freezer when you're
ready to use it do yourself a favor
butcher box for the holidays yeah baby
I've said a bajillion times I love it I
was leaving a house today my wife had a
had a uh ground beef from butcher box
out on the counter the frost
come on and maybe some meatballs two
three of them they do that ground beef
right yeah they do you know why because
they're Monster Box of course uh guys
this holiday season is made uh better
and tastier with butcher box for a
limited time they're offering our
listeners ground beef for Life there we
go here we go again running and gone and
10 off your first order as well sign up
today at butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg to get 10 off your
first box that's butcherbox.com
aygu's code ayg to claim this deal doing
what's your drink of choice if you're
going out to dinner if I'm going out to
dinner I feel like a cocktail you like a
cocktail I start with a martini of
course
I want to be Tom Papa I love my dad
this guy's all right he starts with a
martini
we're just starting we're just kidding
and I don't think he's going to Bud
Lights either
something room temperature please
okay vodka martini I start off with a
kettle One martini straight up dry with
olives nice which means very little
vermouth if I'm making it at home he's a
martini I love them dirty yeah I don't
really go dirty love it uh but I am not
opposed sure I'll go um
even your drinks are dirty I'm drinking
olive juice
two maraschino cherries if I'm starting
at home if I'm at home I'll uh
wait what do you mean you guys are so no
I'm in the way for going out to eat
you're gonna have a cocktail of bass
before you go yeah it depends how long
she's taking yeah I love that but I'll
uh I'll uh you're the best huh really
I'm so happy I'll put it or I'll put the
vermouth over the ice shake it a little
bit dump it and that's all the vermouth
I'll use then it's Kettle one and then
the olives you have a setup at the house
you have a nice bar at the house uh just
like an area the area where all the
where all the alcohol is yeah it's not
in the globe is it it's not in a globe
but there is a globe across from it you
have a globe in your house my wife found
this globe holy [ __ ] we've been asking
that question forever it's in the in the
dining area which is uh right off the
kitchen we have uh the alcohol over
there and then she found this globe like
a stand and it actually has a light it
has like a you can light it up at night
and have the globe light up oh that's
awesome it's pretty cool do you have a
golden retriever that brings you
slippers when you walk in the house the
birds follow you around
I was going to ask him if you ever seen
any jeans
what's the last bootleg everyone
yeah something how do you feel about the
rotisserie chicken uh I like your
rotisserie chicken okay
um I'm the only meat eater in the house
really yeah both daughters uh and my
wife don't eat meat so I eat meat and
then now that we have these dogs we have
a black lab and a Pug and uh they get
very excited like if I'm grilling or
something yeah they're to the point
where like the first move is just taking
the metal spatula or the tongs and out
of the thing and they're like
all right where are we going well let's
go what's up what's up we're going
downstairs and we're gonna Grill we're
gonna come back up the stairs and we're
gonna cut it I would love to know what
your refrigerator looks like on the
inside I bet you it's spotless it's
bright it gets it gets a little out of
hand yeah but uh what are we talking one
of my big things when I travel and then
come back I'll uh I go through and take
all the old stuff out I like to kind of
keep it orderly yeah but it's uh what
kind of fridge are we working with
sub-zero of course is it the stainless
steel on the outside yeah
that's the one with wallpaper on it
sometimes these classic guys they cover
them up with the wood panels no you
don't even know what's there how about
the oven what's the oven uh George
Foreman that's a uh Viking biking yeah
yeah that's where all the bread comes
from yeah yeah what kind of uh Grill
you're working with outside uh it's a
built-in built-in weapon thing yeah
Weber yeah it was like a little island
out there there's gas so you don't have
to switch out propane or anything nice
it's just you got hardwired hard water
line gas in there yeah this guy's yeah
it's pretty good do you have a pool at
the house now yeah you do yeah salt
water in ground okay yeah salt water
pressure
yeah it's not really fresh yeah sure the
chlorinated water I would expect that
from the papa household yeah all natural
yeah just get yourself a cup of water
out of the pool
that's another thing if we do go to your
house right now yeah you know we come in
and you offer us water what would that
water be the water comes from the the
little filter thing on this in the sink
on the sink yeah okay good answer yeah
okay
huh anyone in your family still have an
AOL email address I do you do I kept my
old AOL for my junk okay if I ever if I
ever need to have to log in or they need
an email that's the one they get oh
there you go it's not the only
acceptable answer I'll give you that
right we've had some guests that we're
gonna send to you like a Scared Straight
program yeah so you could reform them
yeah because it is reform like like I
said this is true this is calculated yes
this is learn this is growing you're
missing a period where it was where the
where it wasn't great where Tommy salami
lived
[Applause]
wow talk to me about Thomas these are
the single days I presume yeah this is
like uh yeah after Kyle like going early
going to college going to Ryder going to
Ryder until uh yeah until probably well
you graduate
you know 93 I got into comedy so I
graduated
High School in 86. so like 80s yeah like
86 to 90
three uh-huh early 20s late teens yeah
yeah where I was free to act on my own
sure with all I had known about the
world growing up in New Jersey you know
what I mean yeah yeah
um I want to get back to you so you said
you start with a martini then yes and
and what calculates the next move all
right so if we're out and they cut the
guy comes over Kettle One martini
straight up with olives dry
um they bring then they have that now
you're perusing the menu you're looking
you're perusing the menu would you throw
some apps in to get get things going
yeah yeah yeah definitely like to put a
pause on that you don't give them the
whole order no I like to slow them down
cool I like to slow them down cool off
we're gonna be here a while yeah we
don't I don't need you putting the
entree on top of my grilled calamari
[Laughter]
you're embarrassing me
and Tom are getting out of here as
opposed to the hot dripping Tower you
ever have clam strips
I went to my cousin's kids wedding uh in
New Jersey at like one of these like uh
you know Banquet Hall places and it was
full-on Italian the appetizer room oh I
like it I like their sounds they've had
a prosciutto Tower holy [ __ ] it was a
tower like a wedding cake with just
draped prosciutto
it was amazing the eye rolls you must
throw at comedy club food
I do the haha chicken fingers
yeah all right Dark Days God damn I like
the dinner thing so we're at dinner so
we're at dinner we're gonna get some
apps you're gonna look over you're gonna
look over the menu we're gonna have the
cocktails the first round okay
the martinis done uh usually slide into
red wine of some sort nice something you
know red wine do you know wine DC yeah
yeah I've learned it and who's picking
say you got with another couple are you
is Tom running the show depends who I'm
with right depends who I'm with if uh if
if it feels like uh I would imagine it's
gonna be somebody pretty classy for you
to give up the ring yeah you know I've
got I've got some classy you know shiny
friends I'm friends with Jerry for
crying out loud you know some people
know their way around and uh I'll I'll
let them fall back and let them Drive
the Bus yeah but I respect that but if
it's you know me with my family or my
pals then I'm I'm on it you're calling
it and I've gotta yeah like I've got
from uh from a from a couple have you
ever heard of uh Jim Harrison the writer
Jim Harrison he's died but he used to
write uh all these articles for Esquire
okay all about food he was a monster he
would just eat and drink everything it's
I really recommend a really big lunch is
one of the things that he wrote okay
it's a compilation of all his essays and
he just lived he just ate and he died
like he had like gout
all the problems yeah but uh I learned
wine from him like he pointed me in the
direction of him Italian and French
wines and I used that like kind of as
the guide it was like he's just like and
he's also like hunts and lived in
Michigan it was just like this like
man's man but loved really good wine so
I used that as kind of my life I like
the road map and uh so I know my way
around at least the areas you know I'm
not gonna know every label that kind of
stuff
so expensive or do you like something
sensible uh if if we're out like I'll go
like 150 like for you know what I mean
like if I'm splurging that ain't no sun
or home
you got to figure whatever you're paying
is usually double what you'd sure buy
right yeah so you know if we're out
celebrating or whatever you know 60
bottle of wine but you're really paying
one 150 out of it uh that'll but but
normally I try and like you're I don't
want to drink garbage like red wine
that's that's garbage is going to hurt
you yeah the next morning's gonna be
pretty [ __ ] true true yeah you share the
apps with the with the table are you an
individual app guy
um depends on the place depends on the
place and also like I said I'm uh I'm
the only meat eater true so if I wanna
you know then it is all yours by default
right exactly there you go if you were
gonna die tomorrow and you could have
one meal where would you go anywhere in
the world
oh man I he I'm torn because I feel like
my roots say I should go
full Italian right like I should go to
like my favorite Italian spots but the
the pure desire is Steakhouse yeah like
uh Del Frisco's or someplace like that
where you just don't Frisco is double
legal oh yeah oh boy you know
Gallagher's here in the city yeah I love
Gallery we're a Gallagher's family yeah
I haven't been there in years it's
really it's still Top Notch yeah really
good service is those guys are great
it's like you have professionals career
waiters yeah exactly they're like 55
year old dudes I'm going uh I'm going
Old Homestead on Friday nice yeah I
haven't been yet but I hear good things
it's good it's good I go with my uh I
have I get my uh high school friends
together every day Christmas area I'm in
charge of all these dinners yeah right
yeah
I get all the high school people
together you take them all out everybody
chipping I already chips in okay uh and
we go to the Old Homestead nice yeah
will you be handling the ordering for
that uh I usually let my pal Brian do
the appetizers and there will be a tower
involved yeah yeah there will be but you
know they're you know those things you
really get pretty raked over the cold
you get raped in those places sure you
know but you just go for it but yeah
like the steak the Steak House nights
love them they're my favorite last meal
of your life and probably do that yeah
something else yeah they're the best
give me the porterhouse in a [ __ ]
Manhattan called a day yeah are you
flossing every day I'd say every other
to third day okay what kind of
toothbrush are we working with electric
regular regular regular yeah toothpaste
uh toothpaste yeah
who have you had on this show
I use cheese whiz fatty what do you
think about what kind what are you
rocking uh usually Crest not bad from
the old days mouthwash something that
says whitening but doesn't sure that's
how they get you
yeah yeah are you a mouthwash guy
um I do like a nice old school Listerine
okay uh what color I'll take the brown
really because it just looks God damn
yeah because that's wild dude it looks
pretty nasty like Geritol but I doubt to
say I don't I I don't replenish it as
often I know okay I always start I'm
like I'm gonna I'm gonna be a mouthwash
guy every day yeah this doesn't last I
know I don't understand why are you a
Cologne guy
um a little bit
a little Spritz once in a while you know
what you're using what are you rocking
ah
yeah I don't just something at the house
something hit the house yes whatever was
there when I bought the place so
whatever the other guy likes but
carnucci's left in here
the Ricardo whatever okay Ricardos oh
bottle English leather yeah I don't know
the name of it how about deodorant what
do you what do you use uh I use men in
unscented
pretty classy have you ever known
Stetson or brute no okay what are you
shaving with
uh either barbasol if I'm on the run
okay or uh heels if I've got the time
and we're just using regular razors
Gillette really yeah okay yeah you think
this guy's using a [ __ ] big razor in
school
um hmm how about the shower you pee in
the shower
um in a in a fix really in a real gotta
be jammed up you gotta be really like oh
this game this came on quicker I don't I
don't know exactly what the scenario but
it's very infrequent but if push comes
to shove you gotta get him in there yeah
this guy's bulletproof you're brushing
your teeth in there at all in the shower
yeah no come on no
okay get a [ __ ] gentleman here this
is the kind of guy who meets the
president and then tells you they got a
weak handshake what are you talking
about
do you sneak snacks into the movie
theater no
oh bye I like I like I like the the
process of buying yeah enjoyment of
course what's your go-to uh my go-to is
the popcorn like uh like bigger than I
need okay and then um either uh M M's or
raisinets isn't it raisinet stitch them
into the into the popcorn this guy's all
right pour them in yeah and if you would
you like soda would you have a soda uh
not usually maybe a Diet Coke okay once
in a while but uh yeah in this in the
theater probably water you describe but
water yeah right the closest thing I
ever heard in my life
that's [ __ ] nuts dude
Jesus Christ my God uh what was the last
book you read
uh uh the last book I read was a Jim
Harrison called uh wolf okay called wolf
you read regularly I do you do you're
reading something right now he writes
books yeah yeah
um right now I'm reading uh James
McCourt uh called the passenger huh yeah
he was the guy that wrote the road you
ever see that movie the road yeah yeah
yeah okay the book is even creepier it's
post it's post-apocalyptic him and his
son just like walking through
Pennsylvania pretty much I'm out on
abandoned highways and it's so real
creepy you have a TV in the bedroom
I do but it's there for my wife to watch
while I'm on the road gotcha I don't
turn it on when I'm there so when you
guys are getting ready to go to bed will
you read before you guys go to bed just
now usually
usually I'll read a little bit while
she's getting ready she's slower getting
in okay but I'm usually pretty tired by
the time we get down there you're right
out yeah uh have you ever bought the
floor model of a TV or an appliance
uh
um I don't know maybe okay maybe what
are you whipping around be opposed to it
what are you whipping around La and what
kind of car do you got uh Tesla I have a
Tesla and a uh Volkswagen 1967
Volkswagen you do you got an old school
yeah yeah
pretty sweet it's pretty cool he's
[ __ ] oh we um are we flying first
class uh yeah for the most part for the
most part yeah TSA pre-check yeah clear
clear yeah
when did you get your passport
um my passport not until like probably
95 96 after you start a comedy after I
started comedy okay first trip overseas
was going to uh Amsterdam to perform
perform yeah have you and the wife been
around the world a little bit have you
guys traveled we've traveled we've hit
some big spots but not that much okay
um what's a papa family vacation like
uh a lot of it's been going to the
Jersey Shore we fly back and we see the
family we see the family we get together
with my sisters and their kids and nice
and we go down to the Jersey shua huh
um we've been to Italy we've been to
Africa
Hawaii
um those are like the big ones okay but
we're not a family that like yeah
okay who's cutting your hair
um now it's uh Barber King in uh in
Studio City Barbara Barbara what's that
run yeah uh it's 40 bucks it seems
ridiculous
yeah uh usually ten okay 50 bucks that's
all cash yeah it's all cash are you a
cash guy uh tip cash you got a tip cash
yeah
no I stopped at the ATM on the way up
here because I have a guy
based on the name of your program I
thought this might be a situation where
you gotta throw a couple a couple times
to get out of here we put a bucket up on
the table will somebody else optional
for the holidays
I start ringing a bell have you ever
left a bad Yelp review
no have you ever smoked a pipe yes I
just ordered a new pipe really I don't I
don't smoke the pipes as much as use
them as a prop okay they're kind of a
pain in the ass to smoke what do you
mean like I'll just walk around with it
what walk around the house with it point
at people make a point yeah you you're
fine talk down to my wife you know if I
were you I would maybe take the garbage
out yeah talk to the dog in a British
accent yeah okay you're wiser with a pie
everybody with a pipe tends to be wise
yeah it's a fine line between douche
here and wiser sure you know you get
massages regularly not regularly but you
get you'll like one I do like one they
are actually very helpful now they're
great but uh there is a part of me when
I'm like in a resort or something on the
road and I've got a day to kill and I'm
looking at the Spa menu and it's like
200. they're always so expensive so
expensive and I just picture my father
going what are you doing
you know scratch your back against the
long keep it moving uh we do many
petties no no mani pedis right you know
how to use chopsticks yes hmm
when you're getting dressed in the
morning
do you put your pants on then your socks
or your socks and then your pants uh
usually socks then pants whoa because
the uh a lot of the jeans are a little
more tapered sure so tighter legs
tighter legs so getting the sock up
there after so I've been going more sock
than okay can I just say this is the
greatest podcast of all time
I love this podcast
um all right let's say you're getting oh
what kind of shower you're working with
glass door glass door full door like it
closes or like it's closes is there a
separate tub like a Jacuzzi pool there's
a separate tub nice yeah you guys have a
Jacuzzi out in the back by the pool too
no we don't it's been that's been a
debate it's like
you can get one from Costco you're done
I'll let you do that for five grand Toby
cut this I've got I've got some friends
that have that just did that sure am I
and my wife's like no we're not doing
that thank God there's some [ __ ]
levels over there
sure but that's the way top pop has got
to go with the little one Papa can't do
the Costco hot tub I know but Tom Papa
hasn't been in a hot tub in seven years
stop hoping he's hot though baby
shoulders okay
um what's the credit card situation Amex
rocking and Amex Amex nice MasterCard
Discover card no discover Diner's Club
no dining did you ever have one back in
the day I didn't I didn't I liked all
the jokes about them
call me old school I come from a
different give me a good Pan Am joke
uh how many suits you got at the house
uh
uh I yeah well it's kind of a weird
thing I've got probably eight suits
um but I don't wear full suits the
president I don't wear
I don't wear full suits that often
anymore because it's just uh something
about the baggy pants looked more like I
always think I'm Carrie Grant and I'd
see myself and it look like I'm selling
sure like aluminum siding or something
what are you performing in now so you're
a classy gosh I've got like probably 12
jackets okay not suits just different
style jackets yeah okay whose shops like
who put that ticket did you buy all that
I do all my shopping so you got 12
jackets yeah so I do all my own shopping
I pick it all out yeah I figure it kind
of stores you yeah yo Brooks brother
kind of guy uh Brooks Brothers in a
pinch on the road at the airport you
could like you know you need a shirt
there's like reliable Brooks Brothers I
like Brooks Brothers like classic
stuff stuff is so good yeah it's
certainly shirts man their t-shirts are
great they're uh they're just they're
dress shirts like I found one like white
dress shirt that's like you can't miss
well you just buy like 10 of them then
so you haven't did yeah yeah how many
days a week would you wear a collared
shirt would you say
um I three four days on average yeah you
got a collared shirt a collared shirt
but like you like a polo does that count
does a polo count that doesn't it's a
bowling shirt it's got a collar that's a
bowling and Hawaiian t-shirts yeah but I
would count that I would count that I
put this on because you were coming
I'm trying to get a job here we have a
wedding to go through
kidding me
damn yeah is there ever a day where you
won't shower like if you're just like I
don't have anything or you're like you
wake up in the morning get it Go and
shower yeah all night yeah you're never
just like laying around like I'll catch
you tomorrow you're working out what are
you doing yeah uh Peloton you do Peloton
this guy needs an award from JD Power
killing it dude sharpest comedian in the
world but it keeps me sane it's really
for it's really for my brain yeah yeah
do you own any cufflinks uh I do own
cufflinks but don't own the shirts that
go they use the cover okay yeah the
French girl yeah the big French cuff
it's a lot have you been to France uh I
have been to France but just to Khan
where they were doing like some TV event
okay and uh I had a show at the time we
had to go over there yeah I'm in the
comment I've never been to Paris
you read the paper in the morning I get
the New York Times every day do you read
it every day not really a lot of days I
throw it away at the end of the day but
do you get the actual page but I get the
paper I like walking out getting the
paper I like I mean I like seeing how
news is laid out like on our phones it's
like up to me to decide what's important
sure sure and it's a scam I like to see
like where the weight is like what's
important to them and I like holding the
paper I I bet you look great reading the
news
he looks down over his glasses fantastic
on a nice sunny day sent it to breakfast
nook some fresh fruit on the table the
dog's sleeping at your feet and you got
a fresh time yeah that is a that is a
that is you're describing what I think
about all the time yeah that's a nice
moment how do you take your eggs uh oh
my God that's a great question
over easy over lightly easy
lightly yeah like you just you wanted to
go you want it over but just just for a
second what would be your classic
breakfast you like to go simple couple
over easy egg some bacon or whatever
yeah uh I don't make a lot of bacon
since I live with all these veggies sure
it's kind of like a big thing uh I
usually like if I'm sitting and like
have some time it would be either uh my
sourdough toast with uh two eggs okay
coffee how good is that salad though
yeah that sourdough is legit damn it's
legit this guy's all right you're legit
dude yes
I mean I'm I mean what are we doing I I
you know we're not gonna get We're not
gonna catch him with a sucker punch in
the list in the last round here what are
we doing have you ever crashed gonna
kill the guy
[Laughter]
now we're talking
have you ever crashed a golf cart
uh I don't think I've crashed one I've
taken one I've got an air I've got an
air are you a golfer he still likes to
have a little fun huh it's not a
complete [ __ ] what are we talking
about here
I'll catch some air huh do you do
karaoke never
yeah man of his [ __ ] do you own a
bird no any lizards snakes ever at any
time in your life yes during that period
after college my friend gave me
salami days my friend uh Tommy salami
and a python was into was into boa
constrictors and gave me a boa
constrictor whoa and uh and it started
as a little baby and it was kind of cute
and then it just grew in the fish tank
and every time I'd walk by it would
strike at the glass and you have to give
it a live rodents I'm like this has got
to go back
yeah I uh I no I wasn't comfortable with
it what was your first concert
Van Halen holy [ __ ] you're right the
garden David Lee Roth Jump holy [ __ ]
Guardian yeah yeah wow 84 was the album
was it called 84. I think so 1984. yeah
paying them on jump but yeah jump uh
holy [ __ ] yeah yeah at the [ __ ] David
Lee Roth Eddie Van Halen not van Hagar
yeah not the van Hagar hmm any trophies
currently on display in your home
no okay of mine no yeah will you get
cash back when you make a purchase at a
store no oh man the way the look in his
eyes
I almost said I thought he's gonna hit
you no I mean I have to be really
I got a really gotta be jammed up I
gotta be I gotta I have a lot of time to
be like do you want to give me your CVS
number yeah you want to give me your
movie theater number no I don't I want
this to go quick I'm the same one what
kind of luggage are you using uh I've
got a Toomey wheelie bag with a to me
backpack that goes on top of it that's
like a pilot like a pilot they have they
have like the stack on yeah will you
take your shoes off on the plane never
will you bring food on the plane never
well if I've been coach if I'm back
there with the animals if I'm back there
bring some feed to throw around I gotta
acclimate myself
the money on me I gotta bring food back
there so they won't bite me
but I won't bring like if you can coach
you need to bring your food because
they're not going to give you food yeah
but I won't bring anything cooked gotcha
they dry it's something
nuts maybe some Cheez-Its that can't be
rolling on with a Shake Shack burger no
like Chinese no there's other people on
the plane I'm not bringing them I'm not
bringing food smelly food on the plane
people do it you like a cheese to it I
love a Cheez-It this guy's all right
love a Cheez-It that's that's my
weakness in the airport Cheez-Its the
wall of Cheez-Its forget it you check
out at the hotel will you stop and check
out or just walk ever
of course now let's not only do that
internationally so they don't steal your
identity yeah maybe International I
don't travel internationally too often
but yeah I usually just walk have you
ever had breakfast in bed
uh
uh not really never made breakfast a bit
for for the misses yeah early when the
girls when the girls were little but
then I had a joke about that in my ACT
it's like uh on Mother's Day
uh that it's it's like a torture it's
like you're pinning her down with this
tray yeah you can't like yeah shitty
eggs uncooked toast that the kids made
Happy Mother's Day yeah Fruity Pebbles
I'll be at the diner with the kids
do you ever buy clothes and then wear
them and return them
no
that's a bad habit though hmm But
Goodwill gets them do you have a
favorite candy bar Butterfinger
really yeah I know it's not popular no
that's pretty good that's all right
though yeah it's pretty good it's
forgotten ever been to a Renaissance
Fair uh once for school like and why in
the Tommy salami days went with my
girlfriend okay and a couple friends
that's fun in the kitchen I saw it ate
the turkey leg never worn back okay
hmm ever written your name in wet cement
uh
uh yes will you buzz the attendant on a
flight will I Buzz the attendant yeah if
you need something yeah huh yeah yeah
you like to have a cocktail on the plane
I had a double I had a Double Buzz last
week what later on what happened it was
it's a it was you know it's a lot I
don't want to be the guy double buzzing
sure yeah but I buzzed and five minutes
go by I oh you double buzzed because
they didn't I had been asleep and I woke
up I needed something you know I'm in
the fancy seats you're paying three
grand to get to Cleveland you can double
bucks you know what I mean those those
tickets ain't cheap eventually you hit
him with it yeah
and uh buzzed and nobody came so I
turned it off waited a a minute and then
hit the Double Buzz and I know the guy
next to me is watching me Double Buzz
like who's yours
who's this guy uh but I I needed water
or whatever sure so it was a double list
a little out of character but yeah the
fact that you recognize that
yeah it's crazy are there magnets on the
fridge at your house uh the outside of
that fridge is not magnetic so there's a
couple taped up pictures of the kids
it's cool things
yeah I assume all the uh the cooking
gear the cooking utensils all that stuff
is all top shelf like do you have those
uh the croissant things yeah
those are those are I have two of them
that's what the bread gets baked in
really yeah because you have to create
steam right so you put the dough you
once it's all done and you put it in
there and you spray it with water and
put the lid on it do you have a pizza
cutter at the house yes of course he
does nice set of knives I assume yes hmm
not bad just got sharpened I found a new
knife sharpening guy you have a nice guy
I found a guy that comes and sharpens
your knives to the house he comes he
pulls up in his Prius
he doesn't get out of the car I don't it
was either the options were dropping at
his mom's house this is actually I just
got less classic you're actually
reminding me like he's still got my
number he asked me to get to leave a
Yelp review because he was good he came
up I gave him the knives he came back
the next day and handed me the knives
through the window he doesn't get out of
the car and uh and they're all nice and
sharp and he's and his thing was will
you give me a nice Yelp review and I was
like okay and then I went on it and the
Yelp review
wants to use my email yeah hit him with
the AOL
and maybe I think I have to get like a
new account sure to do it and I haven't
done it I feel bad I'm gonna get them I
got yeah I gotta get it live and breathe
off those [ __ ] yeah have you ever
left a bad Yelp review no
I've never left this guy's flawless I
got I mean what are we doing you pop
anybody else's pimples never never
scratch your back with a fork
not a fork door jamb get in there
there's an old back scratcher that my
grandmother had that's in my office
really yeah in the closet bamboo face a
lot of books in our office good yeah
good amount of books can you play chess
yes
man I don't have people to play with
though
you ever play by yourself no I've tried
on like the phone or that kind of thing
but yeah that's pretty sharp
um what kind of air freshener you got in
the Tesla uh no air freshener
any eating or drinking in the car
allowed
um
when the kids when I would drive the
kids to school once in a while they
would bring something in but it was very
uh but you you would never go to the
drive you would never do the White
Castle move that you and your dad no not
not in the car the car is pretty
pristine okay yeah when you go to the
drive-through we have a fast food every
once in a while or no ah the only one is
in and out
I I stopped going when I was in college
was when McDonald's was kind of catching
a lot of [ __ ] and uh I never went back
to fast food after that really so like
even on the road I won't go in and out
doesn't really count that's a little bit
that's a little yeah it's like Shake
Shack yeah yeah right exactly
man I mean I want to find a whole do you
have any fireworks at the house no but I
actually
yeah
see if the Knife Guy happens next time
it sounds like he knows a guy yeah any
nunchucks Chinese stars anything like
that no
you do karate in public
do you want to as a joke
we eat a hard-boiled egg in public uh
yeah you would I'll get the yeah because
the like the Starbucks okay protein pack
it's got an egg in it can't even fault
you for that cheese
I got nothing
you have baking soda in the fridge yes
of course you do
two of them
boom in your face Maddie
anybody in the family ever claim to have
seen a UFO
uh yes okay yeah I have a picture of a
ghost that I saw in my office all right
this guy's crazy
[Laughter]
that's why we do it yeah here's your
house is haunted uh yeah I had a um I
had one of those Nest cameras put in
are you gonna show us yeah I'm gonna
show you I had one of those Nest things
I don't know if I want to see this yeah
I had one of those Nest cameras put in
my office and I was uh on the road for
the first time and the office is in the
house the office is in the house of my
office you're probably getting haunted
by a Duke who's taking notes on how to
live
people surveilling you who is this man
he's been whispering in my ear all this
time it's probably the government
don't pee in the shower
really
ah man an excellent choice
um and I and you know you get the alert
alert something went off yeah that
something went off and it was my dog I
was like oh that's cool and I was said
to my opening act in Colorado I said uh
wouldn't it be funny that would be a
good beginning of a horror movie you get
an alert and there's just a dude looking
back in the camera oh [ __ ] that I've
seen those online like someone like
trying to get in the front door yeah no
that's not for me yeah so then just I
said that another alert went and this is
the picture it sent back
the only people in the house was my wife
and my young daughter
is it that shadow yeah I mean the guy
the shadow that looks like a guy yeah
yeah that looks like a guy he looks like
he has a gun too and there's nothing
like this isn't on the street there's no
reflection there's no other people in
the house I called my wife I'm like
what's going on there he looks like a
guy in a trench coat yeah that's uh yeah
so that's the ghost the nice office have
you had situations at the house before
where like you noticed or you guys did
you guys know since then burn some Sage
my daughter's kind of freaked out by it
because yeah I asked him to leave my uh
my wife was in the laundry room which is
below that and she thought my daughter
was there and went and said something
and then turned and there was nobody
there oh I'm never going I wanted to go
to your house so bad
um it was nice knowing you
but my daughter is a little freaked out
by the stories yeah what do you mean so
she Burns Sage yeah she Burns sage and I
wanted the spirits out of there but it
doesn't bother you uh no it doesn't seem
like a menacing kind of a presence
man not afraid of ghosts I don't know
this guy's like a [ __ ] fighter fight
I'd be in his arms like Scooby-Doo what
are you talking about
oh we gotta wrap it up 100 class Mr Tom
Papa thank you so much for coming man
brand new thank you special out right
now it's so funny because everything you
asked is why I love it is everything you
ask I've given a lot of thought to of
course okay a very calculated man of
like how to how to live and how to how
to do it most people come in and have
answered no to all of those questions
classy guy uh what else you have coming
up other than the special that's out on
Netflix right now everybody's got to
check it out yeah
um hold uh what a day it just dropped
it's uh
I hope people like it it's really uh
it's packed with jokes it should be good
I named it what a day because that's
what I say all the time I always when I
come in I'm like what a day what a day
what a day and then but it has a
different meaning at the end of the day
which you're like what a day
I'm gonna get me a martini stat gang
he's one of the best I ever do we're so
happy that you came in and sat down with
us kipi what do you got for them out
there uh like I said the third show at
the Gramercy is on sale now get those
tickets please help move those tickies
and then the live stream we're doing
January 1st guys thank you so much for
the support we appreciate it gonna be a
lot of fun gang we love you Mr Papa we
love you thank you thank you so much
again so much fun gang we'll see you
next week